and
respecting anyone
I need to have an intimate on
promise it's confidential it's between
you and me do you feel happy here of
course I'm happy here
aren't you
do you feel you know how she would react
in every situation
I've always had this fantasy that
there's something else out there for me
[Music]
do you want to live mundane lives or do
you want to be part of something special
and unique
you've been selected to live up there
okay well you're wasting your time
because we haven't even been on an
airplane I should I should clarify I'm
talking about you here junior
only you
[Music]
we're going to ensure hen has company
while you're away
[Music]
we're going to replace you
I don't wanna robot living with my wife
I want to leave her here all alone day
after day
he doesn't really see me anymore
maybe I shouldn't be telling you this
I encourage you to use opportunity to
act on your instincts
what if we decide
be together
[Music]